what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and the mha final arc
is blowing up bakugo reveals his
ultimate power as his character
development reaches its climax shigeraki
reveals his ultimate master plan for
becoming the next light yagami and the
god of the new world and deku may
already be too late to prevent a bloody
and tragic ending for mha so let's get
into it you guys know how this works
leave a quick like and comment to help
this video in the youtube algorithm and
of course subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a completely free
way to directly support the channel
right now you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram
at animeopror as usual this video will
contain mha manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned so when we last visited that
massive battle against shigaraki within
the floating ua grounds a small army of
heroes and hero students were all
working together and facing off against
shigaraki and even though monoma was
successfully erasing all of shigaraki's
quirks shigeraki was using his own
mutated body to fight back against all
the heroes an endless mass of giant
fingers and hands was growing out of
shigaraki's body and he was using this
to attack the heroes however it is
important to remember that this strange
finger growth power is not the result of
a quirk all of shigaraki's quirks are
still getting erased this finger growth
power comes from shigaraki's body itself
and it is just as normal to him as it is
for us to grow hair and nails out of our
own bodies this sudden and drastic
change in shigaraki's anatomy occurred
as a result of ujico's unprecedented and
grueling procedure to put it simply when
he received all of those quirks from all
for one including the quirk all for one
itself shigaraki's body began to change
in an attempt to contain the power of
all of these different quirks this is
that whole quirk singularity problem
that ujiko has been talking about for
generations once quirks become too
strong or once there are too many quirks
within one body the body can no longer
handle all of that power and the user
loses control of the quirks and of his
own body human bodies simply do not
evolve as quickly as quirks do and this
is something that ujico had tried to
warn the world about but no one listened
now although jiko's warnings were
ignored by much of the world he
continued to research the problem of
quirk singularity with the support of
all for one and his solution to this
problem was the very procedure that he
performed on shigaraki he basically
insulated shigaraki from the problem of
quirk singularity by drastically
modifying his body which now allows
shigaraki to accommodate more quirks and
more power than any normal human body
the explosive growth that his new
mutated body is undergoing is a side
effect of this procedure in the latest
chapter we return to the big ua fight
with an absolutely wild and shigeraki
just straight up surfing on his finger
mutations as they come closer and closer
to filling up the entire ua enclosure
there doesn't appear to be a limit to
how much of this mutation shigaraki can
generate and so the entire battlefield
is now a huge grotesque mass of mutated
hands and fingers the heroes and hero
students who are there are doing their
best to beat back the progress of
shigaraki's mutations but they just
can't destroy them quickly enough they
grow faster than they are being
destroyed we see sun eater negede genist
miruko bakugo and headshot all
struggling against the mountains of
fingers that are rushing right at them
and it becomes clear very quickly that
trying to destroy all these fingers is
not a sustainable strategy they need to
get past the fingers and attack
shigaraki's main body and they need to
do it quickly thankfully the finger
mutations are not as strong as
shigaraki's main body so they can be
destroyed but again they just keep
growing and growing endlessly seeing
that he has the advantage shigaraki uses
this moment to go full light yagami he
says that with his new body and power he
will create a new world and he will be
the god of this new world currently the
world is divided and full of conflict
but once he takes power and rules over
everyone the gaps between people that
give rise to misunderstandings fear and
rejection will disappear because
everyone will then be equal in
oppression everyone will be equally at
the mercy of the one true ruler of the
world which is a type of equality i
guess bakugou says that he doesn't know
whether this is shigaraki talking or all
for one but he proclaims that he doesn't
want to hear one more word from either
of them although the current
relationship between offer one and
chikaraki inside of this one body seems
to be complex i believe that this is
primarily all for one talking at this
point shikaraki never gave off these
light yagami vibes at least not to me so
i believe that this is mostly all for
one at least for the time being i fully
expect that the real shigeraki will take
back control of his body eventually
bakugou then initiates his ultimate
support item area suppressing heavy
armor called panzer although quick note
we will have to wait for the viz
translation for the official english
name this armor makes bakugo look like a
human tank or a human mecha as a bunch
of high-tech and high-powered blasters
appear on his back and shoulders and
then he begins to fire explosive blasts
all around him destroying shigaraki's
mutations in a blazing inferno the other
heroes rushed to take advantage of
bakugou's attack and as miroko points
out bakugo is finally learning the art
of teamwork everyone is doing their part
and there is no room for individual egos
in this fight because without working
together everyone is absolutely screwed
that's why we have nato and izawa
erasing shigaraki's quirk kaminari and
others giving power to the flying
platform momo and others repairing the
platform amid flight and of course the
heroes and hero students who are
engaging shigaraki directly bakugo
included this really is a massive team
effort and in general i am a big fan of
stories where teamwork plays an
important role the fact that so many
heroes have to work together against
shigaraki really gives us a sense of
this villain's true power and it makes
this final battle more suspenseful and
more satisfying after hearing shigaraki
slash all for one talk about
misunderstandings and how they can lead
to fear and rejection bakugou thinks
back to his own experiences with deku
and we see that bakugo's character
really has progressed so much since the
beginning of the story bakugou has now
accepted his own issues and insecurities
the same issues and insecurities that
led him to bully deku and not only has
he accepted all of this he has owned it
and moved past it in his 1a classmates
he found friends who were willing to
look past his issues and move forward
together with him and so bakugo
proclaims that no matter what it takes
he will burn away to shigaraki's main
body and so great explosion murder god
dynamite still the absolute coolest hero
name hands down by the way uses his new
ability to create cluster bombs to blast
his way through shigaraki's endless
mutations he does this mercilessly and
relentlessly until he comes face to face
with shigaraki himself as bakugo
prepares to cluster bomb the crap out of
shigeraki's face with his ultimate move
a move referred to as howitzer impact
cluster bomb the chapter comes to an
explosive and
man this was intense and bakugou really
was the star of the show in this chapter
his new support item seems to be nearly
as perfect for his quirk as his hero
name is for his personality and thanks
to this support item he is apparently
able to become a human mobile missile
launcher and he is able to make use of
his explosive quirk to the absolute
fullest i love both the design and
utility of mecha bakugou and i am hyped
to see what happens next
in my previous mha video i said that
endeavour is the best written character
in mha by far and i stand by that
nonetheless i do want to throw some
respect on bakugo's name because he
really has evolved and progressed as a
character he's always been a memorable
character in the story but i always
thought that he was kind of an edge lord
with an anger management problem and he
definitely wasn't one of my favorite
characters however in these past few
arcs he has shown a lot of growth and he
is now fully owned up to his past
shortcomings and insecurities i also
love how he refused to make his hero
name more socially acceptable despite
being asked to do so so i have come to
really respect our boy bakugo bakugo
learning to function as part of a large
and carefully coordinated team is
definitely a big deal for his character
but it's an even bigger deal for the
story as a whole because if the heroes
didn't use teamwork during this battle
it would have been all over for them
long ago the big question now is can the
heroes hold out long enough for deku to
arrive because let's face it shigaraki
will not be defeated until deku arrives
the final battle will be one for all
against all for one deku against
shigaraki we all know it but what will
happen in the meantime that's the
question with some sort of threat
currently approaching deku and with him
still being far away from the ua it's
safe to assume that we will be waiting
for deco to arrive for quite a while
so will deku make it in time to protect
all of his friends or will some of his
comrades die in the battle against
shigaraki before deku can get there i
mean yes mha is a shonen so we're not
gonna see like game of thrones or
berserk levels of carnage here but
horikoshi has demonstrated in the past
that he is willing to get bloody and to
kill off popular characters so we could
definitely see some of the heroes or
hero students at ua dying before deku
arrives such a tragedy would emphasize
just how consequential this final battle
is and it would definitely spur deku to
give it his all in the final showdown we
could be heading for a very bloody and
tragic ending of mha where the good guys
win in the end because it's a shonen but
they still make many sacrifices along
the way personally i don't see a major
character like say bakugo dying in the
final war but i could totally see the
mentor characters like all might
endeavor or izawa dying or some of the
less important students like the class
1b gang or someone like kaminadi daku
being deku even a single death because
he allowed himself to be sent to the
wrong location would absolutely break
his heart and his rage and regret would
turn him into a completely different
character at least temporarily such a
tragedy would have a massive impact on
deku's personality during the final
battle and it might even allow him to
unlock his final quirk or maybe even a
new form it's possible that when deck
unlocks his final quirk his body will
begin to change as a result of the quirk
singularity problem i talked about this
before in previous videos but this could
lead to deku going berserk and attaining
a completely new form just in time for
the final battle with shigaraki i am
leaning towards a major side character
dying in the near future and this loss
then triggering deku to awaken a new
form or power let me know if you guys
agree with this will a major character
die and will this change deku and maybe
give him a new power up will the ending
of mha end up being tragic and bloody or
do you believe that we will see a more
wholesome ending when the show first
started i was definitely expecting a
wholesome ending but in these last few
arcs things have gotten a lot darker
than they were before finally what did
you think of bakugo's role in this
chapter and of his character development
in general don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below i
always love hearing from you you guys
know the drill if you enjoyed this video
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes you a second but it really helps
with that youtube algorithm and if you
enjoy our mha content and you want us to
keep it going do me a quick favor and
subscribe and hit that bell right now
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thank you to kyle
salisbury this man is an absolute mad
lad and a disciple of lore twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the red-haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted chi corey magawin the
fallen chosen orihime wukong dante
tinnell and big buddhist finally thank
you also to our pro-hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor bonnie parks fat
boy games kaido might be a duck alivania
and anime s codem if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys